stop
before video begins new g fuel flavor
very cool looking this one's called
miami nights baby hell yeah i've been
trying it out it tastes really good it's
supposed to be a combination of pina
colada
and half strawberry daiquiri
beautiful what's fun about g fuel is
that there's so many flavors and you can
just um try whatever you want obviously
pewdiepie flavor best but this is pretty
damn good and you can pick this up right
now for 30 off if you enter the code
pewdiepie which is a great deal it's
practically a steal this is also valid
on all g fuel energy tubs hydration tubs
shakers and starter kits so if you want
to stock up on some pewdiepie flavor we
got the original in user slash if you
want to pick up a beautiful new tub it's
all 30 off baby you know i love g fuel
it's convenient delicious and cheaper
and better and and at bestest it's the
best
i love g fuel before i partner with them
it's so cool how it's worked out so far
and definitely check out the new flavor
i recommend it it's really good and try
out some different flavors spice up your
life 30 off undercover pewdiepie let's
get on with the video cheers gamers
top 10 most spoiled kids in the world
are you ready look dude it wouldn't be
so bad if you knew how to use all your
equipment set like
give me a compressor you can get so loud
it's ridiculous
top 10 small kids in the world are you
in this video too oh i better not show
up otherwise you're going to have a
problem yeah yeah go tell your dad there
are a ton of kids out there who just
don't know how good they have it here
are the top 10 most spoiled kids on the
planet today
tom cruise and katie holmes has
everything a little girl could dream of
and more she's basically the poster
child for spoiled celebrity children at
this point but how do they know she's
spoiled or not that's what i was
wondering like is she being like a
spoiled brat are they just assuming that
she gets everything she wants because
her parents have a bunch of money she
does look smart
right come on she has to be super
spoiled little sorry recently received a
life-size playhouse worth twenty four
thousand dollars complain oh she's
spoiled what the [ __ ]
all right okay
here's a whole house
she's got a good price on that that's
good real estate
that's gonna be worth uh 10 times when
she grows up it's a good investment
and
there's a kitchen the house keeps feet
tall and features an intercom system
that connects to the main house the
little titanic
very specific and detailed christmas
list every year and even asked for her
own puppy with a sparkling pink collar
and dog tag her mom katie holmes how do
we know this how do we know this how do
they know this how do they know that
they spawn through the window oh yeah
she's asking for that dog again like she
does every year
what happens to the dog after she gets
it she gets a new one over and over
again i guess so cannot miss any item on
that list because if you screw that up
that's years and years of hearing about
it and then probably therapy certainly
even has a team of sisters responsible
for sewing a line of custom dresses
designed by mommy katie her wardrobe is
known to be worth over 3 million dollars
and includes brands like dolce and
gabbana chloe gucci and juicy couture
she's been seen several times in what is
known to be one of the most expensive
toy shops in the world fao schwartz and
recently nice
f.a.a schwartz
goddard so many names fba f-a-a schwartz
hell yeah what kind of toys they sell
just because you get a bunch of
expensive stuff doesn't mean you should
spoil their rich family right mm-hmm
they got more money than what to do with
so why not spend it on their babies yeah
yeah
yeah right staying in cinderella's
castle suite in disney world which was
originally built for walt disney's
family and is usually only reserved for
special events apparently the cost of
staying there is priceless but somehow
priceless
come on it's time cruz there's no price
for tom cruise i figured that was
actually kind of a disappointing
experience for her you're staying in the
castle and she's like oh just like the
movies and she gets there and she's like
oh god
ancient couchier in the rug nice
tom cruise can't go to disneyland so
it's kind of sad like you have this kid
and you go to disneyland and i'm sure
they go they go in the the places like
[ __ ] they shut down the park you know
do they i don't know they'd probably go
for tom cruise
i tell this story a lot i've never been
to disneyland our world without taking
the vip experience yeah
you know i've never had to wait in lines
or anything have you
oh my god i don't think i have either
what the hell we are so spoiled cat
what are we talking
oh my god every time we'd go oh i went
with you a couple of times too like we
would get on a rod and you know how to
take you in the back way the exit and
you just skip in front of everyone
you're watching all these kids they're
so excited they've been waiting in line
it's watching the kids get disappointed
who's waiting in this line way to get a
lot and then like our group of 12 people
come and hop on it see you later
we ride it three times in a row well it
was awesome let's go again guys
they're still waiting like please
oh actually once i once i've went
without and it was pretty miserable not
gonna lie
was it yeah it's not worth it
poor people man poor people being poor
sucks kid yeah i've been spoiled i've
been actually i can't go normally now i
can't no you can't do it anyway spoil
kids dad found a way what a lucky girl
[Music]
oh what an awkward pause
what a lucky girl george is the crown
jewel of the royal family with a cute
little face like that it's no wonder
he's so spoiled the little prince even
has his own trust fund called plank
bridge which he'll have access to when
he gets older
gotta love the trust fund trust fund
chad
you better enjoy that hairways got it
hey
hey maybe they solve it by then who
knows yeah do they get like a then where
they got the what they call it the
implants we got like all the dots in
your head and everything oh yeah it's a
gross
stop it
stop
all right he's received thousands of
gifts over his lifetime and he hasn't
even reached five yet last year how did
he need an ipad for christmas and he's
asking for a small pocket
an ipad for christmas
and oh my god they are so expensive come
on they have cheap ipads now come on
it's tablets it's just gonna give them
the amazon fire for like 80 bucks you
know let me break it do you give your
kids side pets
uh we have the little like weird kid
version thing i don't know i don't know
what who makes them or what they are and
you get
you get these games from the shady app
store
oh really
yeah
they're all free
but yeah the kids love them they just i
love them layla plays a switch now
though i got it on the switch he's
playing that's better yeah yeah teacher
to be a gamer all right you figured out
the system you're worth up to 100 pounds
yeah he's a huge fan of airplanes and
helicopters for his second birthday he
received 706 gifts more than any member
of the monarchy including a toy wombat
an amphibious boat a possum skin cloak a
person a surfboard a bike what and
sheepskin boots on his third birthday he
got us a customer
he's fine
surfboard a possum what was that
that's a possum there's something in
there what was that thing including a
toy wombat oh a wombat
why
that's so specific an amphibious boom
that's four possums man and sheepskin
boots on his third birthday he was
gifted a custom-made rocking horse from
the obamas and a playhouse from the
obamas
you got me thinking we i brought up
watching youtube kids like rap watching
it we always avoid the ones where it's
like a kid like someone else's kid play
with toys are like the little yeah those
are those are weird they are and i also
think about like the family dynamic of
when that becomes like the family's job
or that kid's job and the parents behind
they're like yeah play with the toy and
laugh yeah it's kind of it makes it it's
creepy to me i criticized those before
and they they just acted like such
victims about it like i can't believe he
said that yeah it was really weird when
kids are making more money for the
parents and the parents are making
themselves you're gonna put this crazy
pressure on the kid to keep performing
and wanting to do even though they may
not feel like they want to they'll
always tell you like oh but he's having
fun um
dudes made like 800 videos at this point
come on you know which one is this form
still hey
good point petra and tamara ecclestone
daughters of formula one
bernie ecclestone
oh god they look like those two um i
don't know but then
the eyebrows are strong yeah those are
strong
i'm jealous of those eyebrows man
here they are
they remind me of these duo
the legends
the legend
of jesus
hello yeah you can see tomorrow in her
new reality tv show billion dollar girl
getting free massages weekly manicures
expensive hair appointments luxury spa
days for her dogs 25 000 pound tables at
cans which roughly translates to 33 000
us dollars and a wildly expensive
collection of birkin bags some of which
are valued at 20 000 pounds each she
opts for cellulite removal as opposed to
going to the gym out of laziness and
bemoans the fact that people judge her
saying they see me as pointless and this
really spoiled really stupid vacuous
empty human being so many people don't
understand who i am and judge me on the
fact that my dad has money which must
make me a monster petra well
you can do something to prove otherwise
instead of saying is it because our dad
has money just because she's got a tv
show called billion dollar baby
yeah you know
[Laughter]
you can you can only blame so much on
other people's perception
right
recently purchased the mansion in
beverly hills worth 85 million us
dollars which was once considered the
most expensive home in the u.s she spent
around 12 million pounds not anymore
the one what was it 500 million
yeah whatever that ridiculous oh my god
yeah i'm jesus christ
everybody started linking the
foreclosure on that oh so happy
good happy days took place
italian village of bratiano the same
place tom cruise and katie holmes got
married the wedding featured arrogance
by the black eyed peas andrea bocelli
and the philharmonic orchestra with
lifetime access to their father's 4.8
billion dollar trust fund these girls
are considered some
he's got 4.8 billion but can't get a
haircut jesus christ well when you're
that rich you don't even care anymore
right yeah i guess so considered some of
the richest young women on the planet i
never heard of them
that's interesting
but i mean i don't really care either
like you know it's
i'm sure if we cared about rich people
we'd know who they are but oh yeah
they're a-listers baby oh my girl girl
oh god
you may have come across a video of him
jesus why is he so creepy-looking i
don't know dude look at that face
liberal gem has racked up over half a
million views since it's been posted
i mean she has four mic books that's
pretty outrageous that's at least three
billion dollars according to them
all right
disbelief of how spoiled the girl could
be this little girl who can't be more
than 10 years old is seen on her bed
amongst a sea of macbooks asking for
donations and it's completely wrong
here's the story her mom apparently gave
her the wrong phone for her birthday it
was a samsung s6 and she specifically
asked for the samsung s6 edge
i mean
mom please
okay
if she asks for the edge
she should it shouldn't be that freaking
hard mom
i'm just looking at the room behind her
is it just covered in a sheet what's
going on here i don't know
when you get that wrong gift that you
were asked for and and you have to like
fake smile about it it's like oh thank
you
it's like when you ordered a restaurant
they bring you the wrong food you're
like
yes perfect that's what i wanted thanks
no no i always make a point to point it
out but i never want them to change it i
just want them to know they [ __ ] up
you just want to know i always tell them
and then they almost like oh so sorry
can we get it back i'm like no no i'm
eating it now
but i don't want to wait i need you to
know that you did this wrong
do they ever like bring back the proper
thing and they get like two free things
like you know
it does happen yes
oh
genie that's a big brain yeah sure i
just ended up with two meals and i
regret ever saying anything
upon opening the phone this little girl
got so angry that she smashed one of her
four macbooks she tells her viewers that
her family can't afford another macbook
right now because they had to pay for
her medical bills when she broke her
foot smashing in her macbook she ends
the video by closing up all of her
macbooks explaining how each one is
important one is used for sending
messages one is used for block it's
really nice to have a video explained to
you come on dude what the [ __ ] is this
this is not that's not even real this is
like a this is something yeah this is
something i'm not i'm not buying it
thanks for watching and please donate to
me
that's such an internet hate bait like
nikota avocado or some [ __ ]
hey mate get it hate me
don't click on my video chase mckenna is
a master manipulator she became known as
the most spoiled child in the country
after it was revealed that she can
convince her parents to buy her anything
she wanted despite them not having the
means to do so she demands things like
ralph that's the worst kind of child
she's the most spoiled or her parents
are the dumbest parents
[Applause]
but it's so weird like parents literally
can't afford but they're still spoiling
their child that i don't get like kate
holm's [ __ ] child having a house sure
i mean
yeah they got all the money they could
ever want why not yeah why not make it
like oh
oh darling oh we can barely put food up
there over here like
what are the christmas story with
scrooge mcduck over there and mickey
mouse is cutting the piece of piece of
bread into like a like a see-through
thing
okay well here you go honey i can't say
no to you
because you throw a tantrum and i can't
handle this this is not the ipad
this is a dumb version oh no i'm so
sorry i'll give you buy me five mic
books now
okay five five books oh god
dad
it's gonna be on dr phil soon enough
yeah
i don't
he's gonna be like well you're unders
her because you're the one buying this
crap for you dumbass oh
yeah dr phil has the easiest job there's
no like actual psychology involved it's
literally like what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
she doesn't do primark and claims that
eight times out of ten she always gets
what she wants all she has to do is give
her daddy the face she managed to
squeeze a pony a quad bike and countless
designers
squeeze in a quad bag but you guys are
dead the face is that the face that she
gives him right there
horrifying
no wonder for parents meanwhile her mom
and dad can't even afford to keep
how do you
there you go literally what you were
saying
they're buying produce you know if they
if look if you've ever been to college
in america you'd already know how to
survive off nothing you get those 25
percent rice packs in there yeah oh yeah
you're ready to go
how do kids get so manipulated they
watch youtubers man but like would you
fall for that if your kid came up and
gave you the face like no
no right
how do you not know how to say no to
your child i had to give my kid
just kidding i wouldn't do that but
i know
what do you mean
it's just it's youtube's fault man it's
youtube you know the master manipulators
yeah they're always the ones that have
the youngest audience they see all the
spoiled kids getting all this stuff
right hey look you get to review this
flexing and getting rewarded for it like
i want that
it's probably that's the root cause and
our weight loss
chase's pony eats better than they do
it's a shame she's got her poor
pony had a freaking
that's a chunk chunky boy man that's a
chucky horse right there's a champion
are these like pins all stuck in the
side of the horse's face or they stick
them on there oh that's on the bridle
okay
yeah that is an odd location i will say
that that's what i'm going to do i'm
going to ask you two for another
million reward or whatever and just slap
it on my forehead yeah look
i'm the best bro i told you right
there's a pewdiepie
horse yeah you talking about the
pewdiepie horse that like never wins
races ever how do i bet on this horse i
need
grand that is viking cronus
i need to bet on these horse look he got
last place
i'll just bet that he comes last
yeah
but bro he hasn't done anything in so
long i'm like what did they do to him
look last again what do they do to the
horse
he doesn't raise anymore he just kept
coming last
he's like sandra's little helper and
simpson you came last for the last time
or maybe they just need that one horse
that one horse that always loses make
the other horse look good yeah well this
was named hannibal face what is that
they're all like goofy names okay
apparently no one cares about the horses
they're like ah [ __ ] pewdiepie we'll
name them that
you can last all the time
if someone knows how to bet on horses in
sweden let me know how to bet on
pewdiepie horse you go buy him
i guess i'll have to she's got her poor
parents kelly and ellen wrapped around
her finger you can see her manipulation
techniques in the documentary the 12
year old shopaholic and other big
spending kids you'll see she's got the
face of an angel but behind those eyes
really
i don't call it a child you know but uh
matt
did she call the people to get on a
television show yeah she hooked that up
with her she yeah her parents didn't do
it oh my god no i don't believe it i
think it's fake that's fake instafamous
daughter of billionaires julia stakiva
is known to be one of the richest young
women in the world she received her
first louis vuitton handbag at the age
of nine and has a wardrobe valued at 1.5
million pounds it wasn't until she went
to university did she find out that not
everyone can afford designer bags when
instagram first started to become
popular julia jumped on the trend she
managed to attract thousands of
followers without even trying claiming
that it was easy to do when you show
people how rich you are she's received a
lot of i mean she's not wrong
is this her showing how rich she is
she's dancing this dude's back here in
the background like fishing out
something
she looks somewhere between the age of
like seventeen eighteen and seventy yeah
yeah you're right
you're touring right you're totally
right
i love that you can become famous now
just by being rich because it's
instagram and it's like you got what
people want like oh my god look how rich
you are i will follow you
so maybe i live through you yeah exactly
oh god to do when you show people how
rich you are she's receiving them back
they're being spoiled but julia doesn't
care
for the past few years she's been
impressing her fans with photos of her
over-the-top life yeah impressing them
wow that's so cool you're spending your
dad's money i'm so impressed what
wow and when we say over the top we
really mean it julia sees no problem in
flying to russia just for a haircut her
salon will apparently close down why
would you fly to russia to get a haircut
ken my kids will be the least spoiled
kids on the planet they'd be like dad
can i get pewdiepie keyboard i don't
know
they're gonna be like dad can i have
some food like here's your dried dog
food whatever it is
get the dog food
you poop
strong poop
strong you be viking
fight norway
but dad you have so much money can we
buy real food
[Music]
they'll go through the like spartan
regiment training oh you're going to
kick them at the house when like six a.m
yeah they have to survive in the woods
to prove their worth first
meanwhile you know maya's over there
eating her her dog oh yeah she's gonna
yeah
we give my a chicken i cut them in tiny
pieces
oh yeah so she doesn't have to trim it
too much i would call her spoiled but
the poor thing she
she needs
see the way we treat maya i'm really
worried that i would if i have kids that
would spoil it because maya is like
beyond spoiled
but she is really cool too yeah she's so
old so cute and when you like pet her
she's like so she's the softest dog in
the world she's so shy
thank you you squeeze her too hard and
she farts and it's hilarious
anger you know he gets treated like
trash because he is trans
you make him sit through your
you gotta show him how the universe
works and he's like
okay
you're the second sibling all right you
get the sh just for her and a few
friends and provide food champagne and
music for the evening all in celebration
of julia's haircut but hair isn't the
only thing this big spender splurges on
celebration of her haircut cool that
means you have a lot of achievement in
your life if you have to celebrate
getting a [ __ ] haircut you did it
please please fly back and spend a lot
of money i'll get your haircut here
that is something i noticed rich people
do they celebrate way more than poor
people and it's like the weirdest stuff
too yeah like just normal stuff that
happens oh wow yay celebrate party
hooray hooray confetti yeah
what's up with that i don't know i
always get asked like if something
happened to me and they're like oh
you're gonna celebrate right i'm like no
what the [ __ ] i don't know
why would i do that you're gonna open
champagne tonight i'm like yeah well no
i don't what
i feel like you're you're an affluent
person and it happens like all over the
line yeah we're like
no i'm just gonna watch netflix like i
normally all right
at 25 she has spent over 180 000 pounds
on cosmetic procedures and has been
quoted as saying anyone can be rich not
everyone can be beautiful
[Music]
okay
no that's definitely not true you can
pay for surgery i've seen the shows
i've seen the tv shows transformations
oh mackenzie
spoiled team mckenzie was launched into
youtube fame when she totally freaked
out over her birthday present being the
wrong color her dad gave her a sports
car as a gift but to mackenzie's
surprise it wasn't the blue model that
she wanted the second she opened her
eyes the claws came out you can see her
scream do you think this is real this
screams fake too to me i feel like she
would have like looked a little longer
if it was real like
like she just like soon she opened her
eyes no
completely losing it over the fact that
the car is red instead of blue her
brother ryan is filming the whole thing
laughing to himself as mackenzie breaks
down into a classic tantrum she screams
at her brother in a fit of fury to shut
up and begins to hit him
i just feel like yeah this is the car
you get what are you gonna do
no there's nothing with the wrong color
yeah but what do
[Laughter]
i don't get it surprised this is what
you get dummy be thankful
i mean you want to be happy about the
gift you got it but still like
yeah but if they're throwing a tent for
tantrum what the f
there's a thing that mary tells our kids
when it comes to food it's like you
don't have to eat what you don't like
but don't complain about it it's like
mary cooks this food and if the kids
complain about it she's like i don't
want to hear it don't tell me how you
don't like it you don't appreciate it
just don't yeah that's good yeah yeah
it doesn't really work they still
well i would be more like what are you
gonna eat it
i'll just be you just be hungry then me
do you have any like spoiled stories
from your childhood from my childhood
yeah
remember ever being spoiled my dad built
out my he built houses like he was a
contractor and he built our house so we
like had this nice place and everyone
thought we had money but we didn't
uh
and then i just kind of played video
games all the time so i don't really
as a kid you just want a game console
that's all you want so it doesn't i do
remember i i was the only kid for like
six years so i guess i was pretty
spoiled and i was like yeah
you [ __ ] her yeah we were being like
really upset uh we we played uh coach
pitch you know uh baseball right and
my friend was going on vacation and he
was telling me about how they're going
on this vacation and i wanted to go with
him so bad and i threw this huge fit
about it just a gigantic meltdown i
remember
like just being like why can't i go i'm
like we're like good friends i want to
go oh my god i mean i get i get that my
mom was just like oh my god dude we got
this [ __ ] i'm having to leave
chill out bro y'all did you get to go
then
no egg no
good parents great
see i am under the impression that no
one thinks they were actually spoiled
but they probably were right yeah do you
think people that were spoiled think
yeah no i wasn't giving anything i don't
know i don't think i was spoiled so i'm
kind of like i don't really know yeah
you don't know i mean i did get usually
the stuff i wished for on my birthday i
just i remember being like real whiny as
a kid like wanting to get my way i do
remember that my sister wasn't born
until i was like seven so
well i just compare myself to my sister
so for me it was i was never the spoiled
one because i was the one getting the
stuff that she got but two years later
oh the hand-me-downs yeah yeah
yeah no i was never spoiled because
compared to my sister i wasn't okay mom
and dad and one time they forgot to
bring me a gift from my birthday this is
the saddest story prepared to cry they
forgot to buy a gift so instead they
wrote a card of what the gift was gonna
be like oh we're gonna buy you this
never got it
never got it this is what you could've
had i never i got a card
of a gift for my birthday
i never got the actual gift i wanted a
guitar an electric guitar and i never
got it mom and dad well there's probably
a reason for that your parents are
probably like no i'm not getting you
that we don't want to hear that crap
like but mom i want a drum set nope
sorry i mean i did get the
video when it first came out i also got
the latest phones when they first came
out sometimes i got phones sure you
weren't spoilers you talk about getting
hand-me-downs you know you're getting
all the new stuff when it comes out yeah
i probably would spoil i think the
reason why i don't think i was that
spoiled when i was a kid is because i
had a cousin that was way more spoiled
than i was i remember having a birthday
party and this this person threw a big
tantrum because
they wanted to open my gifts
and uh someone else wanted to open your
gifts yeah for my birthday right no what
the [ __ ] for this psychos
exactly then someone ended up giving her
one to open up what and then then they
cleaned that toy and i was like
excuse me
you're not getting that ninja turtle
that's like the most precious thing in
that whole universe
i remember no one's touching that that's
messed up yeah and if you're watching
this video and you know who you are yeah
i never forget yeah you're never getting
anything
i remember getting a ninja turtle
submarine a submarine what i had a
submarine holy [ __ ] there it is oh my
god oh my god i did i have this
i didn't have this one so
my granddad gave me money for my
birthday and i'm like two i'm buying two
submarines
i need another submarine
well michael care parents gave me money
they'd send me like the card or whatever
that'd be like you don't even read it
you just open it up and the money falls
out and you go yay and you throw the
card down
it's such a submarine like it leaked
water too such a dumb ass [ __ ] what
did it do did it have like a trigger
that squirted water or something don't
know but you could put your turtle
inside and go make it go under water oh
then when water would get in it you're
like
how am i supposed to play with this in
the tub
i had the ninja turtles where the
[ __ ] dopest
they made a whole cartoon just to make
us want more toys it worked well i was
trying to find i had like a mitchell
angle up who do you have michelle angela
don't know
mr langlais the orange one
michelangelo no mr like
shut up
you're a goddamn mom when i was 16 my
parents finally let me out of the
basement when audrey turned 16 her
mother bought her a lexus then mtv built
a show around it and made the world i
remember this [ __ ] was one of the many
that teams i don't remember watching it
but i do remember it was such a terrible
show sweet 16. and soon afterwards
everyone wanted a car for their 16 right
that's an american yeah yeah yeah
yeah you get your driver's license when
you're 16.
she became famous for her out of hand
temper tantrum that she threw on mtv
cameras all because her mom gave her her
present too early which was alexis by
the way audrey stormed out of her party
and sent everyone home canceling your
birthday nice it wasn't even the car she
wanted anyway how long grateful can a
person get who knows if she ended up
with the guy i need you you can only
hope that she's grown out you ruined my
life
how can you do this god but it's a
parent's fault right yeah yes yes yes
you're born your genetics your
personality it's going to kind of lean
the way it's going to lean but then the
outside influences decide on how it's
going to be and their parents obviously
have failed her on that good deep with
that one did you like that that was
beautiful
damn
did you get a lot uh lions from your
friends
no heck no i didn't get allowance me
neither
dude uh jesus this is another story from
my childhood i would save up my money
you know as kids do and my piggy bank
and i had a hundred and eleven dollars
one one one damn oh i was a saver too
holy sh i remember i had like insane
amount of money because i just grabbed
it from the house like all the change
and yeah
insane and mine and one it was ten bucks
yeah like my dad would like leave the
chat i'd be like oh yeah yeah
one day i woke up and you know i was
like oh let me check my money you know i
hadn't looked at a while i gotta put
some dollar i found in there taking your
savings account
no
parents my parents that is forbidden it
was falling on hard times when we needed
groceries
it is sad and
they didn't
quite understand i was like oh it's my
money i've been saving it up you took it
from me and they're like yeah but we
need groceries
like years later they were like here you
go here's the back you know
here's your money back
we understand we realize what you're
saying when you're a kid you know we
sorry that we should have said something
about it first instead of just taking it
from you
uh but yeah that is kind of sweet and
wholesome i was like well you know
thanks thanks my money back where's my
interest at mom and dad yeah four
percent at least
mine had a lock on it so they couldn't
do it
[Laughter]
locked away
oh yeah for bratty mindset it has
learned to see the merit in luxury cars
our moms did ruin the party
her monthly allowance is a hefty 1000
okay explain why this car is like all
the rich kids want it it's a [ __ ]
off-road vehicle they're just gonna
drive it around l.a it's so dumb i can't
understand it it's just a trend like
everything else but bro
going to be way more comfortable in
another car like what are you doing i
think she has her own youtube channel
now i think she kept on going with her
spoiled ways yeah yeah and all the dr
phil is trying to get some sort of yeah
that's pretty much why they go on there
5 000 to which nicolette claims makes
her feel like a peasant nicolette has no
future goals besides wearing designer
clothes being rich not working and
driving
they all have cameos too
that really says you're living the life
of luxury if you have a cameo
right they start taking the bus but
nicolette doesn't care rats tend to
think that way nicolette was recently
featured on dr phil where she had to
head to head with her thumbnail dr phil
to help out at a soup kitchen to try to
show her how other people live nicolette
still wants her g wagon but has led up a
little bit on her mind it's a good
looking car but what the [ __ ] i don't
understand all these kids running a
[ __ ] wagon
maya henry daughter of successful
personal injury lawyers
is one of the most spoiled teens on the
planet her instagram is simply littered
with celebrity selfies featuring
listeners like justin bieber one
direction and hillary clinton putting
the most rich kid in mr worldwide
her 15 i feel like i met a lot of rich
kids because they are like the ones
coming to those behind-the-scenes uh
signings yeah yeah i just realized back
in the day when the network would set
that kind of stuff up yeah but are they
are they waiting to get that access
because i never got no money for it you
know yeah
same how did this happen
[Music]
it's sweet though the parents just want
to make sure their kids happy i don't
really have a qualm with them yeah you
want to meet you want to meet pewdiepie
don't you worry baby i'll get you
backstage and meet him and
they go back i'm a big fan you go no
pictures
i just think
it's fine to spoil their child as long
as they're thankful right right that's
the thing right if they're not thankful
then what's the point right
yeah
birthday celebration was featured on
mtv's my super sweet 16 and will
probably go down in history as being one
of the most lavish events ever recorded
mr henry spent more than six million
dollars on her epic night out he brought
in her favorite recording artist nick
jonas and pitbull both of whom i love
these artists accepting these like
private birthday party deals here's
something that's where most of the
budget went to right there those guys
show up oh man it's so weird that people
do that i was thinking the best part as
a child
was when like christmas time comes or
birthday comes you get that toy catalog
and you go through the toy catalog and
you're like i'm so exciting that was the
best part the kids don't have those
anymore i'll just get on the internet
and you can you know
it's not gonna it's not the same
come on
is that nostalgic i mean i remember
actually thoroughly enjoying looking at
like just looking at the papers and like
oh yeah oh that'd be so cool yeah
i'm also here are we looking at her
is this a picture of someone taking a
selfie this is some meta stuff right
here dude yeah love it and we're
watching it and they are watching us
watching it it's great oh my god went in
on his festivities with maya and her
friends the party took place at a 55 000
square foot venue that was especially
renovated for the party and featured a
wall of roses 30 foot tall cherry trees
and a ballroom full of butterflies maya
showed up in a 20 000 dress with hair
and makeup by kim kardashian's personal
face artist she changed into several
different gowns over the evening which
together were worth over half a million
dollars happy birthday indeed
when did kim kardashian became like the
face of luxury i don't know when she
married kanye maybe i don't know just
say thanks to your parents you're
grateful tell them thanks for all the
gift you got mom thank you for
the ipod video that was cool that was
the first one i had of it that was do it
i got another thought for you another
scenario
oh oh my god here we go poor ken again
being poor no no no this is just
families in general if you ever have if
you ever have a kid or or whatever oh
gosh
you will love your kids more than they
love you back yeah i think so yeah as a
kid you kind of maybe take your parents
for granted and you know you're just
kind of like yeah mom and dad may go
through your teenage years yeah it takes
you forever to realize your parents are
people just like you
yeah and they really cared a whole lot
about you by that time they're like you
know 80 years old they can't hang out
with you anymore
and then you have your kids when you
have your own kids you realize you're
like oh my god i love these kids so
freaking much so you think about how
much you cared about your parents you're
like oh that's so sweet it's not the
expression that you you don't own your
kids your kids own you i guess that's
the same
i think that comes down to your time
because all your free time kind of goes
with them right
yeah it's a big game good times man well
there you go most spoiled kids be
thankful
be thankful and show you're thankful by
smashing like and subscribing on this
video check out
yeah don't subscribe to candles you can
actually watch my videos got any more
dead subscribers thank you
there you go
i have new merch represent.com super
happy about this so i think you guys
will like it check it out